Você pode estar pagando caro por algo
que está fazendo o oposto do que
promete. Um estudo publicado no Journal
of Dietary Supplements em 2023 analisou
72 das marcas mais populares de óleo de
peixe do mercado e descobriu que 45%
delas estavam rançosas,
quase metade. E o pior, muita gente não
faz ideia de que está consumindo produto
oxidado. Hoje eu vou te mostrar os três
sinais que ninguém percebe de que ser
ômega-3 pode estar te prejudicando em
vez de te ajudar. E olha, isso não é
teoria. Um estudo clínico randomizado
conduzido pela Universidade Miguel
Hernandez na Espanha, publicado no
International Journal of Food Sciences
and Nutrition, comparou mulheres tomando
ômega-3 de boa qualidade com mulheres
tomando ômega-3 oxidado. E o resultado?
Quem tomou óleo de boa qualidade teve
redução no colesterol total de 246 para
217 mg por dil. Já quem tomou o óleo
oxidado, o colesterol nem se mexeu, ou
seja, pagou, tomou religiosamente todo
dia e não teve benefício nenhum.
Então vamos aos três sinais e presta
atenção, porque são coisas sutis que a
maioria das pessoas ignora
completamente. Primeiro sinal, o arroto
de peixe. Esse é clássico. Se você
toma-3 e fica com aquele gosto de peixe
voltando, aquele arroto desagradável
horas depois, presta atenção. Um óleo de
peixe fresco de boa qualidade, bem
processado e bem armazenado, não deveria
causar isso. Barroto de peixe acontece
porque o óleo está começando a se
degarar.
As gorduras poliaturados do EPA e DHA
são extremamente sensíveis à oxidação.
Quando oxidam, liberam compostos
voláteis que seu estômago não consegue
processar direito. E aí vem o refluxo
com gosto ruim. Muita gente acha que
isso é normal com3 não é sinal de
problema. Segundo sinal, cheiro forte ao
abrir o frasco. Isso aqui é um teste
simples que você pode fazer agora. Pega
o seu frasco de ômega-3 e abre. Se vier
um cheiro forte de peixe, de maresia, de
algo que parece estar passado,
desconfia.
O óleo de peixe de qualidade tem um
cheiro muito suave, quase neutro. Alguns
descrevem como uma leve aroma de mar,
mas nunca agressivo. O cheiro forte
indica que já houve oxidação
significativa e aqui entra um problema
sério. Os fabricantes sabem disso. Por
isso, muitos adicionam saborizantes como
limão, laranja ou menta para mascarar.
Um estudo de 2024 da George Washington
University mostrou que 68% dos
suplementos de ômega-3 saborizados
excedem os limites de oxidação
considerados seguros. O sabor mascara a
rancidez, por isso cápsulas sem sabor
adicionado tendem a ser mais honestas.
Se cheirar mal, você sabe que tem
problema. Terceiro sinal, você não sente
nenhum benefício. Esse é o mais
traiçoeiro. Você começa a tomar ômega-3
esperando reduzir inflamação, melhorar a
função cerebral, diminuir
triglicerídeos, proteger o coração.
Passa um mês, 2 meses, 3 meses e nada.
Você até faz exame de sangue e os
triglicerídios continuam igual. A dor
nas articulações continua igual. E aí
você pensa, será que ômega-3 não
funciona para mim? Na maioria das vezes
o problema não é você, é o produto. O
insto espanhol que eu mencionei mostrou
exatamente isso. O grupo que tomou óleo
de qualidade teve redução de quase 30
pontos no colesterol e redução
significativa nos trigliceridos. O grupo
que tomou óleo oxidado, praticamente
nenhuma mudança. O problema é que nenhum
trial clínico que testa 3 em humanos
reporta o estado de oxidação do óleo
usado. Então, quando você vê um estudo
dizendo que o ômee 3 não funciona, a
pergunta que fica é: será que não era
óleo rançoso? Geralmente é. Agora, por
que que isso acontece? As gorduras
ômega-3, especialmente EPA e DHA, tem
múltiplas ligações duplas na sua
estrutura química. Isso as torna
extremamente benéficas pro corpo, mas
também extremamente vulneráveis ao
oxigênio, luz e calor. Quando essas
ligações são atacadas pelo oxigênio,
formam-se compostos chamados aldeídos,
como mal de aldeído e o qu hidroxi
2xenal.
Esses compostos são problemáticos.
Estudos mostram que podem ter efeitos
pró-inflamatórios e até mutagênicos em
altas concentrações. Ou seja, você
compra ômega-3 para reduzir inflamação e
acaba consumindo o alvo que pode
aumentar. E tem mais um dado
preocupante. Pesquisas sobre DH oxidado
e doença de Alzheimer mostraram que
quando o DH se oxida, ele não só perde
seu efeito protetor no cérebro, como
também pode aumentar a produção de
betamiloide. A proteína associada
aoimer. É o oposto do que você quer.
Então você compra o ômeega-3 pensando em
proteger sua memória e pode estar
acelerando o problema sem saber. A GED,
que é a organização global que
representa fabricantes de ômega-3,
estabelece padrões de oxidação, mas
esses padrões são voluntários, não
existe fiscalização obrigatória. Cada
fabricante decide se quer ou não quer
seguir. E mesmo os que seguem, muitas
vezes testam produto na fábrica, mas não
controlam o que acontece no transporte,
no armazenamento, nas prateleiras ou
depois que você abre o frasco em casa.
Um óleo pode sair bom da fábrica e
chegar oxidado na sua casa. Então, como
se proteger? Primeiro, faça o teste do
cheiro. Abra a cápsula, fure com uma
agulha, cheire. Se o cheiro forte,
desagradável, descarte. Segundo, observe
se você tem arrotos de peixe frequentes.
Se tiver, troca de marca. Terceiro,
prefira cápsulas sem saborizantes
adicionados. Elas são mais honestas
sobre o estado do óleo. Quarto,
verifique a data de validade e o
armazenamento. Ômega-3 deve ser guardado
em local fresco, escuro, idealmente na
geladeira após aberto. Quinto, procure
marcas que informam os valores de Totox,
que é o índice de oxidação total. O
padrão da indústria recomenda Totox
menor que 26. Quanto menor, melhor. E
uma dica extra, considere comer mais
peixes gordos de água fria, como
sardinha, anchova e salmão selvagem.
Esses peixes oferecem ômega-3 em sua
forma mais protegida dentro das células
do peixe com antioxidantes naturais como
a aschantina. é muito mais difícil
oxidar do que um óleo extraído
encapsulado. Um estudo publicado na
Frontiers Nutrition em 2023 mostrou que
sardinhas contém não só ômega-3, mas
também cálcio, potássio, magnésio,
zinco, taurina e arginina, todos
trabalhando juntos de forma cinética. É
a comida de verdade fazendo o que sabe
fazer. Agora, se você optar pelo
suplemento, que é o caso de muita gente
que não consegue comer peixe
regularmente, siga essas cinco regras
que eu falei e principalmente não aceite
arroto de peixe como normal, não é? Se
seu ômega-3 tá causando isso, você tá
consumindo um produto que pode estar
fazendo mais mal do que bem o seu corpo
merece qualidade.
Aqui no YouTube eu preciso simplificar e
omitir protocolos mais específicos.
Sobre ômega-3, por exemplo, não posso
detalhar as marcas que realmente passam
nos testes de qualidade ou os valores
ideais de Totox que busco pros meus
pacientes. Na comunidade fechada, eu
compartilho tudo sem filtro, protocolos
exatos da clínica, incluindo quais
marcas eu recomendo e por como
interpretar os valores de oxidação nos
rótulos, combinações que funcionam,
fornecedores confiáveis, interpretação
avançada de exames, lives semanais, PDF
com 47 protocolos, grupo no WhatsApp,
clique em Seja membro. E no nível dois,
a cada duas semanas, fazemos imersões de
2 horas e secando artigos científicos,
como os estudos sobre oxidação de
ômega3, que a indústria prefere ignorar,
debatendo controvérsias e bastidores da
ciência. Seu nome aparece nos vídeos
como agradecimento, é o ciclo interno de
quem quer ir além. E já que estamos
falando de ômega-3, você precisa
conhecer os 15 sinais de que seu corpo
está com deficiência. Mesmo que você
esteja tomando suplemento, se o óleo
estiver oxidado, você pode estar
deficiente sem saber. assista esse vídeo
aqui que vai te mostrar exatamente o que
observar no seu corpo. Agradecimentos
especiais aos nossos membros queridos
dos estudos avançados da comunidade
fechada do YouTube. Começando pelos
novos membros que entraram recentemente:
Walter Salgado, Luciano Silvo Polinelli,
Luciano Elias, Carlos Roveri, Odonor
Pinheiro, Cíntia de Assis Oliveira,
Jorge Cabral e Fernando Machado. Sejam
muito bem-vindos. Agradeço também aos
membros que fizeram upgrade por os
estudos avançados, Irma Carol, Iana
Medicina, Adriane, Dra. Ana Paulo
Rodrigues, José Fortunato Murtinho, Sou
Jucioli, Cristina Carol, Romana Moraril,
Estela Mares, Eloterapias Integrativas e
Saúde, Luís Anselmo Neves, obrigado pela
confiança em elevar o nível de
participação. Um abraço especial aos
membros que retornaram à comunidade,
Alex Caldas, Marcelo Pimentel e Cláudia
Leitão. Que bom ter vocês de volta.
Quero fazer um reconhecimento especial
aos membros mais fiéis. Estela Mares com
incríveis 57 meses de fidelidade. Dr.
Ana Paulo Rodrigues com 45 meses de
participação, Marcelo Pimentel com 24
meses e eloterapias integrativas com 10
meses de história conosco. A todos vocês
eu agradeço de coração pelo apoio
prestado. vocês fazem a diferença nessa
comunidade. Ч.